we're here in e3 2018 i'm so excited
we're heading in this is my first time
on the show floor the first place that
we're going
is to nintendo so let's go oh
oh my there's zombies
look at him he's gonna get that gun
is it cosplay or just an activation
oh he's following me he's following me
[Music]
okay so we made it booth let's take a
quick tour and then we're gonna head up
to some gameplay
[Music]
this is like a nintendo museum
hello
it just it just doesn't ever get old and
it makes me cry every time
it's okay it's a good guys they're happy
cries
yay brings back so many great memories
like my childhood
oh my gosh i can't handle it okay okay
i'm composing myself i'm sorry
thank you so much i appreciate it my
pleasure oh my gosh yes thank you
have a great time okay okay i'm
it's like one of those things like when
you guys come up and meet me and i see
you guys in tears
like you can't actually understand it
until you have that same feeling like
this is crazy oh my god i'm so
i'm an emotional mess right now it's
mario
[Music]
hey what's up good to see you guys we're
back can you believe we're here at
another e3
i know right i feel like this just
happened like last week i saw you uh
you're playing mario odyssey
i was i was right there that's right you
were yeah here we are again very
it feels familiar this year we're
bringing on some super smash brothers
ultimate
everybody is in there pokemon let's go
pikachu pokemon let's go eevee
yeah yes it's super exciting i know
right yeah but i'm excited about smash
brothers yeah no i'm not the best smash
brother so do not judge me
even though you will because this is the
internet and i know you guys because
that's okay
be nice come on it's okay what's wrong
with you do we get to play yeah let's
play okay
so our first demo that we're gonna be
playing is super smash brothers and i
know all of you guys are excited because
i've seen you on twitter just going
absolutely crazy especially while the
nintendo direct was happening well guess
what it's here
we're gonna play it we've got a smash
brothers cheat sheet
for the noobs which unfortunately is
probably gonna be me because i haven't
played in a very long time
activated and you get some healthy
little character oh this looks like what
you did
oh yeah we both did one so
yours player two as you see is that bird
that's coming out next week yeah that's
the heck out of me
and as you know some of the levels are
very easy i guess
and other ones really have elements like
dangerous elements that the levels will
evolve as you're playing some are very
small
you've got all sorts of like weird
little villager abilities it's awesome
they take a while but they hit yeah
mario tennis cheat sheet
oh i was looking at your screen i went
the wrong way i keep i know we're
standing on
the other player's side so i keep
looking at his screen
okay okay here we go
[Music]
oh yeah i'm getting the hang of it now
uh i almost spoke too soon
we are really excited for uh mario
tennis aces because it's after the 22nd
oh that's soon i know like a little more
than a week
that's always the hard part about going
to e3 is you see all these games that
aren't going to be coming out for a long
time
yeah you know actually that's kind of
that's kind of what we do we you know we
have games they're gonna be out in a
couple years right of course but
but uh we were like like show people
what is coming out soon what are you
gonna be able to play
you know now or before the holidays
fortnight
now dude i'm so excited when the
announcement happened i was like yes
this is what i've been waiting for
yeah i can't wait but this is so much
download your copy of fortnite already i
did lots of people did
yes yeah i haven't got a chance to play
it because i'm obviously here but
it's ready it's ready
so the first two hours was media so
there weren't many people but now they
open the doors
and there are so many people everywhere
call of duty did already get a chance to
play when they did
the multiplayer review
jurassic world let's go
this is such a cool booth gotta get my
dinosaur selfie
you guys want to see it look at that
[Applause]
[Music]
are you three been it's been good how's
yours been it's been overwhelming you
were at the pro-am a little yesterday
i was it was for a little bit but not as
long as you've been in that heat
but it was so you did a really good job
thank you
i had to leave but i was watching you in
the car on twitch
so that was thanks jen you want to go
check out the mixer booth
we should go say hi to larry let's go
see if we can see how to larry
[Music]
i just crossed the street
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i actually i actually crashed the
stream
it was a joke but the joke turned
reality
[Music]
[Applause]
hi pj how's it going cheers cheers we
can do a walk and talk
okay because nick is now a ronin pro wow
look at us
just walking walking and talking talking
okay wait wait don't run into the people
and then pick up the conversation okay
okay so we're going to reenact ready
okay
um hey tj oh hey justine how's it going
that's going great how are you doing
cheers
cheers how's your e3 going it's
fantastic i love
it so many great games here to check out
have you had any specific moments that
have been your
key highlights if you thought uh hideo
kojima walks by in front of me
and that was like full body chills did
you cry a little bit
okay so i ran into the voice of mario
and i actually cried
yeah the tears they were real if you
guys
remember this moment ed saw it holy cow
friends at e3
this is a great chat we're all
professionals i'm gonna start crying
and cry okay so we've all cried you
cried kajima i cried
because of mario oh you cried once i
cried toys let's let's play those bags
[Music]
i can't even handle it
my heart stops for a second and i'm like
that's that's hideo kojima
now i just feel uncomfortable did you
get a chance to see nintendo do you
haven't tried it
tomorrow yeah tomorrow yeah so i got to
play smash like right when e3 opened up
11 a.m yesterday nice what do you think
so much fun
it's like it's really crazy
uh first time i chose link and then
second time
i chose inkling because i want to play
with the new youtuber too yeah i played
inkling and i played villager that's it
cause we played on the animal crossing
one and we played the mario galaxy
levels it was really fun
yeah did you play the okay i keep what's
it called the battle um
battle arena stars light star
link battle star star yes but
atlas battle of just like that star
romance guys
starlink battle for atlas yeah yes great
game it's like destiny no man's sky
it was really fun that's what we're
trying to get to is the game was really
fun
you should play it okay it was great
no open back up fortnite on switch
i know we've talked about it a million
times but i'm excited about it
i'm excited to play it not connected to
a chair i'm ready for
a fortnight vr give me four night views
okay now you're getting crazy that would
be so much fun
that's called real life construction oh
yeah so i was going
to construct a job although yesterday at
the four day program
the program was almost sort of for night
real life because we were all outside
so i guess that's really the only aspect
too it's a really bad analogy
anyway we're gonna be heading into the
xbox event this isn't the showcase event
that we went to before have you been
inside yet yeah
oh what can we expect uh there's forza
there is a sea of thieves whole bunch of
cool stuff there
there is what else did we see ori is
already there um
there's the adaptive controller in front
of an adaptive wall
um yeah the wall is changing
and kudos to microsoft with that
adaptive controller it's really
incredible i mean i've heard so many
amazing positive things that i feel like
more game companies need to
sort of address this this is something
that they need to start creating so
that's really exciting
i think it's a quite a challenge because
of how many
ways that there are to uh interact but
creating one source for all that to go
into and then be compatible with stuff
that people
can easily just buy off a shelf yeah
like
playing video games and needing access
to specific controller types
there wasn't compatibility there now
knowing that there's compatibility for
all those different
inputs is fantastic yeah they've kind of
created that hub to make it accessible
for everybody which is yeah which is
really awesome
well let's head inside you guys want to
go in you're already there so let's go
let's
see it again i don't know why i'm
running i'm running because we have a
ronin and then we can
[Music]
hold the copy very carefully yes
uh
at sea of thieves
never forget that chocolate lancer it's
life-changing
[Music]
they've got the battle bus oh i'm sorry
no way this looks incredible does he
know i'm here
does he know that i'm here do you know
that i'm here
i think he knows i'm here he's getting
closer
what if i go this way
do you want some coffee
[Music]
this booth is so awesome they actually
won an award for best booth at e3
rightfully so they've got popcorn
they've got cookies they've got a llama
bull riding thing they've got supply
drops they got the battle bus
so i don't want to do this because the
last time that i did something similar
to this like on a bowl
i got severely injured so let's just
live vicariously through them
[Music]
hey look it's my friend my best friend
hello hello i'm a beacon of
attractiveness
hi hi i mean we've been running around
all day and we just meet up at the
fortnite booth
i'm just exhausted i bet you are yeah
yeah
how's your brain after being fried
outside for
numerous hours well i've been drinking
coffee and caffeine non-stop
okay well i'm feeling great we survived
the pro-am we
that was the funniest clip by the way i
said do you guys like memes cause i
think this is one
yeah and uh it became it it was good
but the event was amazing i was so lucky
to cast with you well i wasn't casting
you guys were doing all the casting
we were a team team effort it really was
team teamwork makes the dreams work
even in a thousand degrees heat yes and
i could have asked for a better team
you guys were amazing it's so good to
see you again
[Music]
that's it for today's e3 video i've had
so much fun so far this year there's
been so many fun moments
that hopefully i was able to capture
some for you well i'm gonna go
and i don't know what i'm gonna do
probably gonna edit or drink more coffee
or do something i don't know maybe i'll
boogie down
probably won't but maybe oh i'm sorry
am i doing it no um
no still not
[Music]
[Applause]
you